well I'm sure now by Richard twice he's
property developer and co-chair of lief
means leave Sir Richard mark stone
saying there that business is very
nervous about a No Deal scenario should
they be well I think what the Prime
Minister needs to do is to make it very
clear to Brussels
she made a generous offer in Florence
she shouldn't negotiate against herself
that's you know a very poor negotiating
taxi she needs to make it crystal clear
that unless they respond in a equally
constructive positive and generous way
that actually we're going to walk away
because what businesses want is some
certainty and they want this process to
be accelerated they've been so many
mistakes made in these talks we should
never have allowed this sequential
process to take place the torch
should've been going on 24/7 seven days
a week
not one week in three or four here that
there's no way in business we would run
this process like this but she needs to
say we're going to publish our WTO plans
we're going to give confidence to
businesses consumers and the public
alike in Britain and unless we get some
progress in the next couple of weeks
literally two or three weeks we're off
oftenly
and the crucial thing is she must then
say there's no money from March 19 so
really think before the end of the year
she should be able to prepare to say
right before you know November
businesses want some action and if we
get on with it
it just gives extra months and weeks for
businesses to plan to be honest any
sensible well-organized well-run
business now is planning on the basis of
No Deal which is absolutely fine as a
base case after all
WTO of course is what most great
countries trade under if it's good
enough for Australia and for America and
Canada it's good enough for the UK but
what do you make then of the fact that
people like the Federation of small
businesses the EF of today said they're
really really worried about a No Deal
scenario me what do you know that they
don't and it's the CBI these are the
same organizations that dreamt up
project fear they've dreamt up this
cliff edge they're now basically
rerunning project fee around three four
or five we've lost count you know they
were wrong then they're wrong today and
they will continue to be wrong tomorrow
let's remember the CBI they didn't back
Thatcher's reforms in the 80s they
wanted us to stay in the ERM and the 90s
they wanted us to join the era these
people have a track record of being
consistently wrong and they should be
ignored by the public at large when
fairness the CV I would say they're only
in favor of joining you
for about 18 months and then they came
down against it just look at their track
record you know all the big issues of
the day these people have been wrong
look at the entrepreneurs people who
understand cash flows putting risk on
the table as opposed to the corporate
managers the entrepreneurs people like
great people like Dyson like Peter
Hargreaves like Tim Martin of
Weatherspoon's those are the people that
people should listen to they're quite
happy today to go to WTO very
interesting you make this point about
the sequential nature of the talks I
mean Wolfgang Munk Chow in the FT today
saying actually there is a point now
it's impossible to reach a deal on
citizens rights and Northern Ireland
until we know exactly of trade you go
along with that completely and we should
never have allowed its you to tapirs
it's actually contrary to the the
wording of article 50 anyway it's
basically illegal
we shouldn't have allowed it they need
to stop that they need to say we've got
to put everything on the table we've got
to accelerate it and it really has to be
24/7 and what about what does a WTO exit
with No Deal look like too because I
mean on the show last word we had David
Tyler the chairman of Sainsbury's
warning that food prices would go up 22%
in the event of a No Deal I know we keep
getting these scare stories you know
from people are that the truth is UK
supermarkets are already looking to
source more product domestically the
truth is we'll start buying more oranges
from South Africa as opposed to from
Spain because of the tariff distances
businesses businesses will adjust
consumers will adjust and if it means we
buy more wine from Chile and Argentina
or South Africa Australia and less from
France so be it it's not the end of the
world very very briefly Richard Philip
Hammond should he stay or should he go
well if he's going to stay then he needs
to take some happy pills and you know
become much more optimistic and set out
a really positive future for the UK what
we're really worried about that leave
means leave is that actually what he's
trying to do is to trap us into sort of
new brexit membership of the European
Union that would be the worst of all
worlds he really does need to focus on a
much more optimistic future
Richard Tarr so I'm glad see you're on
your happy pills anyway thank you for
joining me thank you